-As is tradition when you´re
here, a glass of wine, cheers.
-Cheers.
-Always nice to see you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was worried that you wouldn´t
want to have a drink tonight
because you had your premiere
last night.
-I am morbidly hung over.
-Morbidly hung over?
Now, is this always something --
Do you tend to drink a lot
at all your premieres?
-No!
[ Laughter ]
This was your first time?
-I really never do this.
No, well, my entire family
was in town.
-Got it.
-A lot of friends came in town,
and all my friends are alphas.
All of them.
-Okay.
-It was all of us.
-Alphas?
-Yeah, we´re just all --
-Okay, I thought you were
saying, "alchos,"
and I was like,
"Is that short for alcoholics?"
-My best friends are Alpacas.
So, yeah, we were just shouting
each other out last night.
-And is that --
Does that fit with --
-This coats the throat.
-Yeah -- this is a -- but you
obviously, a film premiere,
especially a film like this,
which has, you know,
there´s -- It´s very artistic.
Is it strange to be
at an after party
where you and your friends are
just screaming at each other?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, okay.
-It´s not normal, but yeah.
And it was also an odd choice
for me to have my entire family
come just for
this particular movie.
-Yeah, did you warn them?
-It was a weird choice.
-Did you warn them what they
were going to see?
-I warned them and anytime --
I wasn´t really wearing a bra
a lot ´cause, you know,
I´m like Mother Earth,
and my dad was sitting next to
me and every time --
I just had forgotten about that,
and every time there would be a
shot my dad would go...
[ Gasps ]
-Oh.
So the scariest element of this
to your family --
-Was the outline of my nipple.
[ Laughter ]
My dad´s been talking all day
about how Ray Donovan
was at the premiere.
-Ray Donovan was at --
-Yeah.
-So Liev Schreiber --
-Yeah, Liev Schreiber was there.
-Okay, was your dad excited
about that?
-I was like M. Night Shyamalan
is here,
and he was like, "Ray Donovan?"
I was like, "I can´t talk to you
about Ray Donovan anymore."
[ Laughter ]
-I will say my dad would be very
excited about Ray Donovan too.
-Yeah.
-I think it´s a very
dad-friendly show.
I think all dads picture
themselves as Ray Donovan.
-Yeah, it´s like -- it was like
the Liam Neeson, like "Taken."
-Yeah, exactly.
-The speech.
-You know they all did that
in a shower, every dad.
-Oh, my God.
-Oh, my God, what kind of place
are you running?
[ Laughter ]
That was disgusting.
-It´s not a big deal.
We have one mosquito,
and he has Zika, but --
[ Laughter ]
It´s fine. I wouldn´t worry.
-That must have been
hard to find.
-It was, but we have a budget,
and so we went out
and did the work.
[ Laughter ]
And so, afterwards --
so, your parents, they --
Do they come to premieres often?
-Not really.
I mean, like the whole family,
it was kind of rare, you know?
I mean, there´s just always --
and my brothers --
Again, it was just
a weird choice.
I had my mom --
-Your mom seems like
the fun one.
-My mom is a character.
-I feel like that´s something
similar we have
because my mom´s
the fun one too.
-Yeah, I brought a boyfriend
home to Kentucky one time
and my dad smoked us up
a hog butt to celebrate.
-Now, when you smoke up
a hog butt, does it --
[ Laughter ]
Does it physically
look like a hog butt?
-Like a big juicy...
-Yeah, but does it?
-No. It just looks like
pulled pork.
It just looks like anything.
And my mom -- my boyfriend at
the time was like eating it,
like kind of against his will,
and my mom leaned in
and she was like, "When I saw
that dead naked pig on the spit,
I couldn´t help myself.
I leaned in and gave it a kiss.
Wouldn´t you know it, two weeks
later, I got ringworm."
[ Laughter and applause ]
It´s really good.